هل صعب انه احنا كبشر نميز انه هاي من
انتاج الاي اي وهاي انتاج بشري صعب احنا
في عنا على فكره محضرين كم من اغنيه او
مقطوعه موسيقيه واحنا بدنا نحاول نحذر عن
جد ما عنا اي فكره
[موسيقى]
هذه
وانت بطلت
توجعني
[موسيقى]
الله لا يسامحك
انا سامع صوت جماله يقول يعني
[موسيقى]
منك
انا اقول لك ما ادري انا
ما ادري احس انه في عندها
يعني
انا اللي
نسخه معدله
نسخه معدله بالذكاء الاصطناعي بصوت شيرين
انا اشعر ان شيرين لديها احساس ما موجود
طيب يلا شنو المقطع الثاني سمعونا
[موسيقى]
العازف حقيقه ولا مش حقيقي حقيقي
انت هيك برايك كيبورد
[موسيقى]
عزف حقيقي
حقيقي طلعنا
اللي بعده يلا
اكيد ما ادري
لا اعتقد مش حقيقي
لا كتير سمبل بسيطه يلا دام
حقيقي يا وسام
[موسيقى]
انا صح
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات